You, are a ninja
* Throwing shuriken *
Aaaaaahhhhh!
* Angelo Janotti & Kathy Collier's "Against The Ninja" *
Aaahh! * Thwack *
Aaaaahhhh!
* Smack *
Aaaahhhh!
You're a f%#@ing maniac turkey
Ha! * Explosion *
I'm sorry Uncle
Brenda, I'm your Uncle!
I really appreciate your bravery, ha, you're quite a guy
Really?
* Smack *
* Fighting *
Stop it you fresh
Look kid, I'm sorry
Females are nothin' but trouble
* Automatic gun firing *
It's a rat cage out there!
When you get to be my age...
I hate you!
Come to think of it, you never will get to be my age
* Upbeat music * La la la la la laaaaa la la, la la la la la laaaaa
He's the one who murdered the baby
What? Really?
* Scary strings music * Muuaahhahahhaha!
* Whoosh *, * Explosion *
* Slice * Aaaahhhh!
Hey Colleen, you've got a great ass
So do you pilgrim!
* Purple People Eater song *
* Real Life's "Send Me An Angel" *
Would you like to f&#k me?
Bingo!
Have you been circumcised?
Yeah I have, why?
Well your doctor must a cut a big portion of it off
No he uh, he was a good doctor
I wanna see your face when I kill you
* Slice * Aaaahhh!
Noooooo!
* Fireworks exploding *
Aaahh!
Aaaahhhhh!
Aaaaaahhhhh!
* Guns firing *
* Zombies moaning *
* Screaming *
* Rocket firing *
Aaaahhh!
* Bubbles popping *
Aaahh, aaaahhhh, aahh, aaaahhh!
Aaahh, aaaahhh!
* Angelo Janotti & Kathy Collier's "Against The Ninja" *
My father, I've found my father! Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god